as the veteran ad carry for cloud nine
sneaky has had quite the impressive
career and during week three of the 2017
na LCS summer split he finally got his
1000 lbs kill project over to the pros
on a secret or epic party in honor of
this achievement we put together the
best of keiki on cloud nine
I started playing League and just
casually and then I started going high
up in the ranks like who's the one I got
nineteen hundred and I stood on that and
then season two I went all the way up to
like 2650 I just played a lot of solo
queue and then people start to notice
you still go to high it's going to be to
the sky for queue weekend they're going
to try to fight scar it goes down Kiwi
kid is forced to walk away from the
situation they're going to watch this
inhibitor Churchill down ball is balls
is very low they may try to capitalize
on one kill but it's a double kill for
sneaky coming in it does not look like
he can stop them d king of the battle
here we go Tyrus still in front Reggie
taking some flack as well the fact that
says it hasn't happened Tyrus taking all
the codons does go down that was the
reengage Reggie flashes four double
kills so far for sneaky I was going to
walk out here comes the rep you will
let's find much triple kills super
sneaky and the battle continuing on
they're going to Lance the Morris low CG
is not done he is chasing one more time
for special diffic Quadra kill will they
give him the Penta on the wild side
flashes away and balls is not gonna make
this what happened little Chuck over
wildturtle says hi I'm sneakier after
all didn't I'd sneak he is a Penta we
have to shout out that though the
crystal arrow hit the invisible twitch
so that was a lot of TSM damage that
wasn't there while dyrus was tanking all
of cloud nine you could see how Claude
then were able to take down tower so
quickly once it'll runs into an Oracle
and delayed Penta kill rarity house
videos flying because they're in a twice
or no so deep he's practically in the
end zone by himself
hi take them down this could be it think
he takes on Reginald three have fallen
for team solo beta fourth going down as
I hit the guys with their eyes on the
Nexus their eyes on the summer split
completely undefeated the theory 25 and
3 on the flip
Wow 9 does not drop a single game in the
playoffs and look at that almost
everyone going down
cloud9 go to end the series 3-0 they're
going to take down the Nexus and there
the North American champion
[Applause]
their overall kill/death in this series
is ridiculous they only died six times
this entire series cloud 9 has to funnel
in here and they get the cop cop has a
free chance to shoot everybody who's
what an amazing rocket a four-member
attack and cops down the outside getting
good damage down balls off me the next
want to go down the plasters are getting
out language feels great attack cop does
get a reset there sneaky is very healthy
one shot could kill a few caught off oh
my god
one shot to kill a few that's what he
needed then here it comes
think he's going to turn it around and
he ties up squad four kill from cheeky
Nicky going very aggressive over the
wall luckily does not get pinched out
now on to high here they really want
this one they're going to go full on to
the Kassadin and actually he gets out
with a sliver of health should be having
more than that as a start high heat from
self alive with the help of the team
think he turns around for a nice
collateral damage double kill and now
it's on to slooshy cloud noun nine have
found a fight that they wanted in the
middle of the map and they are just
going to take winter Fox out on this you
can almost see it as it started out go
sneaky down goes imagine sneaky turns
around to get another one really triple
kill Avalon is going to be doing his
damnedest it takes out sneaky but he
scoots just to the left
Avalon flashes over the wall and it is
going to be the triple kill is sneaky
puts out a dancing shoes well get out of
it fifty who's going to get this kill
right now the engage is still an afro
though exactly look for Tomblin speak
against the Cal 710 bonus gold and
they've already cleaned up by as well
return will see a pro also goes down 54
boat is theirs rich another trade it's a
2 / 3 overall Erin's up smithy goes any
five sticky is it the damage they need
though fitting the backline but he's
going to go down so I important has to
go for balls who cares about that so
horse 200 way nothing CLG can do another
couple of kill for sneaky into the
inhibitor they go well we were screaming
a lot more with like open mind just
because of how much more time we had
normally before throughout the weeks
would be reluctant to really try and
like crazy pics like say all this
carry jungler supplies doing probably
wouldn't have tried to do that if we
didn't have an insane amount of time the
corpus very kind of temperate fight here
no dodo have her in from the backside
really heat things up lemonnation goes
down immediately
no more shields from him you should get
taken out so he cannot help control his
own now Nellie troll still has a good
amount of damage but sneaky has little
he has to kite
he has the quadric he'll 17 to 9 cloud 9
going for the last of the base great
positioning that fight fight sneaky in
here without the shadow submit they get
taunted it's part of it there's a jumper
to the side football buys a lot of time
and gets jump somebody sneaking the same
now lemonade you try to run away very
low on health
Zeke Harbinger is on and that's a couple
of kills picked up with the two-for-one
it pay one it adds a huge fight of water
per stinky comes through holy cow cloud9
taking off ash cloud dime get through
first sweep and they're going to face
Team Liquid that's going to be the Nexus
that's going to be the game that's going
to be a trip to the World Championship
book club where we find it Korea it was
the worst flyer Nikki probably get like
the most like thick
she wasn't Messi is on a team
oh okay that's not looking good for you
like think he's taking over time is
honey them all all right I say that just
cuz I stream actually night I yell - oh
my god get shot great pick his moment
jumps in goes to the assassination so
much pressure put on cloud nine they
lose to GA Oh
elder dragon
[Applause]
what was that oh yeah yeah oh it's very
good it put a giant little break and
let's run parent o DW she is the opening
act is Arif going in on a medial it's a
bit isolated jumped over a lantern I
will goes in an impact camp I find it
now come here these are them insistence
peered up / the way pops a bit of damage
in the zone is comes out and now Sarah
Jordan angel pop going to revive grumble
dica across the backline do they have
the damage beaters propelled to the air
in fact left alone a pilgrim difference
pinky make back to he's gave it a steam
alive aquatic universe taking classic
you know safe to camp
and cloud 9 Mike Ditka - oh here they
have the power to push down this mid
lane but an opposite front line and gets
hooked by food these folks would be dead
I was thinking able to take him down
and in fact fighting an Ori we'd now get
on the side as well as got a pop on his
head diving back in over get another
double killed a sneaky escape you get
locked up by the deadly Florida stopped
the car to get back in and clean it up
an exhausted staff thinking in terms of
a triple kills it all settles and period
the only one that there's a Quadra
stinky getting it another passer Esau's
and stinky picked up a pentakill hard
will take this fight in the bottom tires
look at the wars on the bottom side here
for fox they pretty much know they can
just keep going our game is over if you
sneaky back to the other side every
starters venues the shrine on sneaky
from [ __ ] as well when I find the
bottle in the pillar caches bio cross
who doesn't ever weigh out a boys does
the imposter cray helpin out double its
in danger he's going to go down a double
kill for CJD nine to be throughout Lee
in the bot lane they don't get defy and
that that is something that is not that
easy to pull off
that's all I know definitely hey all
right
so farm now what actually insane what is
life you spread the right to a man
without a baby doesn't [ __ ] Sparta but
as in regardless that is just the most
insane field that we've seen in a very
long time Bulls infertile convicts over
to the force on a secret or epic there
it is kill
congratulations you join mm Wow third on
the [ __ ] screen time that was the best
of sneaky on cloud nine what's your
favorite sneaky play let us know in the
comments below thanks for watching if
you want more great content be sure to
hit that subscribe button